if you want to be successful in Tech you
need to move fast and break things
that's exactly what I said to my boss
before he fired me for deleting a
production database I should fire
the relational database management
system is one of the most successful
ideas in the history of computing SQL is
1970s Tech that still forms the backbone
of the modern Big Data World Oracle
dominates Enterprise while MySQL is the
primary database for platforms like
YouTube and Facebook but SQL is by no
means perfect in 2023 there's a whole
new wave of futuristic Cutting Edge
avant-garde game changing databases
looking to move fast and break things
some of them build on top of existing
relational patterns While others bring
entirely new ideas to the table that
you've never seen before no pun intended
over the next few minutes we'll look at
15 crazy ass new databases and talk
about the problems they're trying to
solve first on the list we have Planet
scale which is not a new database but
rather a serverless platform for MySQL
like I mentioned before YouTube uses
MySQL however back in 2010 when it was
getting popular it was extremely
difficult to scale at least for an app
with millions of simultaneous
connections instead of switching to a
nosql document database they developed a
library called Vitas which makes some
trade-offs to scale MySQL horizontally
and this is the technology that planet
scales based on it provides a fully
managed database that can scale with
vtas and makes it available from a nice
dashboard with sdks to go along with it
and it also integrates nicely with tools
like Prisma it has a free tier and good
pricing on the page here that they're
likely losing money on by comparison a
basic database on Heroku is 50 bucks and
it's unreasonably expensive on AWS and
Google Cloud Planet scale is not the
only company with this serverless
database idea though yoga byte has its
own open source solution for postgres
its goal is to scale infinitely in the
cloud but attempt to support all the
native features in postgres which is not
easy to do in a cloud native environment
you can actually use a multi-cloud
strategy to host your database on
multiple clouds at the same time
eliminating the dreaded vendor lock-in
issue but there's another option for
scaling postgres called neon it's
currently in technical preview but looks
extremely promising it's serverless and
can scale down to zero and has a highly
polished admin dashboard to go along
with it and most importantly it's
written in Rust which is the only thing
that matters if you want to look cool in
front of your friends it also supports
branching which I think was inspired by
another database called dolt this
database would be like give MySQL and
git had a baby most importantly it
allows you to create branches from the
main database where you can experiment
with new data without breaking things it
makes it easy to analyze the diff
between changes and when everything
looks good the changes can be merged
back into the main branch and it's done
with the same conventions found in git
that virtually every developer is
familiar with dolt has a hosted option
but it is quite expensive they've raised
21 million dollars and because I'm
extremely entitled I demand they burn
more of this money to give us a free
tier I just paid eight dollars for a
dozen eggs and can't afford to put
another fifty dollars on my mom's credit
card now another sequel flavor I want to
talk about is cockroachdb it's been
around for quite a while and was
developed by ex Google employees and is
often referred to as new SQL it's
compatible with postgres but was built
from the ground up with go to scale
horizontally in the cloud it has a nice
free tier pretty similar to Planet scale
then becomes pay as you go pricing after
that it's yet another great option but
you might also want to consider
Foundation DB or titanium DB as well
which are also in this new SQL class but
in some cases you might prefer a
lightweight alternative like cloud flare
D1 this is a brand new product that's
still in beta and basically it's a SQL
Lite database that runs on the edge
cloudflare already has its own key value
store for workers as well as R2 for
object storage but D1 allows you to
create data on the edge that can be
queried one trade-off though is that
native transactions will not work
however they're taking a very cool
approach to overcome that limitation by
allowing developers to write stored
procedures with JavaScript which are
just Snippets of code that run directly
in your database which can be used to
create transactions or other reusable
queries this approach has a ton of
potential because historically store
procedures are a pain to work with but
if it's in JavaScript even I could do it
pretty cool but it's not production
ready yet if you want something that's
ready to go today check out Zeta yet
another serverless relational database
that's based on postgres and
elasticsearch under the hood but what
makes it special is that it treats your
data like a spreadsheet it feels kind of
like a developer friendly alternative to
airtable or notion and what's really
awesome is that it has full text search
built in without needing to duplicate
your data in some other service like
algolia it has sdks for typescript in
Python and has a schema editor that
makes it very easy to create and
visualize relationships between tables
and it can also do branching like we
looked at in adult DB for pricing it has
a solid free tier then it scales up in a
linear way based on usage but another
tool that takes things one step further
is eight base it's also a relational
database that provides a graphql API for
your data out of the box making it
similar to tools like hasura what makes
it unique though is that it also comes
with a low code tool for quickly
building front-end applications that
connect to your back end it's like a
backend as a service that can also build
your front end but that's enough talk
about relational databases now we enter
the post SQL ERA with Edge DB it's a
graph relational database that's powered
by postgres under the hood when it comes
to relationships humans don't naturally
think of columns and rows but rather
objects connected to each other like a
graph instead of defining tables like
you would in SQL you define types like
you would in most programming languages
these types link to other types which is
awesome because it eliminates the need
for joins and simplifies the way you
make queries overall all it almost feels
like an orm for postgres that allows you
to think about relationships in a far
more human friendly way currently it's
open source and can be self-hosted but
there's a wait list for their cloud
service now another relational graph
like database is surreal DB it's written
in Rust and I have a full tutorial on my
second Channel Beyond fireship it's
designed to support acid transactions
while scaling horizontally but what I
really like about it is how easy and
flexible it makes data modeling for the
most part it feels like SQL but also
uses arrows to connect nodes and edges
like you would in Cipher with a graph
database like neo4j it takes the best
elements of relational document and
graph databases and combines them into
one easy to use API currently it can
only be self-hosted but they do have a
cloud service coming soon the
multi-model idea is nothing new though
another database pushing the limits is
fauna it was created by X Twitter
Engineers who set out to build the
perfect database it's extremely easy to
use like a document database similar to
mongodb but unlike a document database
it supports features like native joins
which is the number one missing feature
in document databases and that means
fauna is more well suited for complex
relational data like social graphs to
interact with it it has its own custom
query language called fql but also comes
with a graphql API it is a closed Source
product so you can't self-host it but
its fully managed service has a nice
free tier another new database you've
likely never heard of is memograph it's
a drop in replacement for neo4j which is
the gold standard for graph databases
but memgraph is focused on building
real-time data pipelines like neo4j it
can be queried with Cipher but it's
written in C plus with a memory first
architecture that claims to achieve
better performance overall it looks like
it would be a great choice for building
something like a real-time analytics
platform next up we'll look at Key DB
which is a faster alternative to the
already extremely fast redis it was
recently acquired by snap a company that
needs to fetch data as fast as humanly
possible it can handle over 1 million
operations per second on a single node
which sounds like a lot to me but it's
not something you would use as your
primary database rather it's mostly used
as an in-memory cache to duplicate high
priority data from another database
making it load faster for the end user
it also has a library called mod.js
allowing you to extend the database with
your own custom commands and
functionality with JavaScript another
specialty database to look into is melee
search the full text search engine space
is dominated by tools like elasticsearch
and algolia a melee search is an open
source rust-based alternative that makes
it easy to implement an awesome search
feature into your app it's not a primary
database but instead a place where you
would duplicate data that needs to be
searchable in complex ways like you can
fine-tune different parameters to
control which attributes have a higher
ranking in the search in addition it has
a bunch of client libraries like instant
melee search that can quickly Implement
a search feature in a front-end web
application and finally that brings us
to mindsdb a database that integrates
popular machine learning Frameworks it
created a concept called AI tables that
embed predictive models directly into
the database at first glance it feels
like SQL except you can use it to write
statements that train machine learning
models when the model is done training
you can then use select to make
predictions from it so basically it
provides an into integrated way to
handle the ml Ops life cycle and it can
also integrate with your existing
machine learning models or those from
third parties like hugging face or open
AI in the not so distant future I
believe in betting AI directly into
databases will be a huge thing and
mindsdb gives you an idea of how that
could look and now you have 15 different
futuristic databases to choose from for
your next failed side project good luck
with that if I missed anything let me
know in the comments and if you want to
learn more about awesome serverless
databases like firestore and superbase
support my work as a pro member on
fireship iO thanks for watching and I
will see you in the next one